j'allais partir dans un hôtel 4 étoiles
tout compris mais vous savez ou à jean
liebart on est
et très long des séries d'amour refuser
si tard merci je vous en prie avec les
hyènes hôpital
si le vent 11
les séries je vous le dis il paraît
qu'ils avaient une surprise pour moi
vous pouvez rester parce qu'il fallait
qu'il avait une petite surprise pour moi
à eux et je les ai découverts je crois
que cette surprise je sais pas si elle
est là mais apparemment elle va arriver
sur scène puisqu'il ya quelqu'un qui
voulait absolument me faire une surprise
et une déclaration ce soir
[Rires]
l'enjeu
c
[Applaudissements]
le dakar
mia frye série
tu m'as cc pour moi oui tribaux ont fait
toutes mes chéris mais c'est un ami mort
mais tu es magnifique tir et alors tu
m'attends pas pour danser
apparemment tu veux danser avec moi elle
veut danser avec l'animal là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savoir la phase un peu avec toi fois
olala c'est que ma chérie tu sais que tu
sais que je t'aime tu sais que je t'aime
je pouvais pas faire ce prime sans que
tu viennes me rendre visite en plus
c'est ton anniversaire
merci
[Applaudissements]